en tout cas plus l'enquêté avance plus
le déroulé des faits fait froid dans le
dos aux quinze personnes sont en garde à
vue dont quatre collégiens il y a eu un
contact entre le tueur et des parents
d'élèves qui dénonçaient les caricatures
on appris également que le terroriste a
distribué de l'argent aux collégiens en
échange de renseignements sur le
professeur assassinés alors dans
certaines zones l'école est elle
réellement gangréné par l'islamisme
radical place à notre décryptage avec
nos invités et pour en parler nous
sommes avec alexis poulard
éditorialistes bonsoir à vos côtés
jacques mignard mer les républicains de
maisons laffitte c'est dans les yvelines
bonsoir alors avant de vous entendre
jacky milliard un témoignage celui de
rodrigo arenas c'est le vice président
de la fcpe
c'est la première association de parents
d'élèves il a reçu un signalement
vendredi dernier faisant état d'un père
extrêmement énervé après la publication
en place d'une caricature de mahomet
regardez on en parle ensuite c'est que
nous avons signalé cela aux maires
homero pourquoi parce que nous avons
estimé que ce qui était diffusée sur les
réseaux sociaux étaient suffisamment
probants pour craindre un trouble à
l'ordre public et dans d'autres pays
ceux qui sont en charge de l'ordre
public dans une commune ça s'appelle le
maire qui ensuite évidemment travailler
avec les services de police pour éviter
les débordements quel qu'il soit c'est
pour cela que j'ai fait prévenir le
maire qui m'a fait a rappelé dans la
journée pour me dire que toutes les
dispositions ont été prises sur la ville
de conflans sainte honorine
suite à ça ces messages qui circulait
sur les réseaux sociaux et que
l'éducation nationale parfaitement au
fait de l'es22 cette situation mettez
tout à disposition toutes les procédures
normales
en tout cas pas les procédures qui
existent pour ce type de cas ouais il a
donc prévenu le maire les maires en
première ligne jacques milliards vous
êtes en charge de l'ordre public alors
l'islamisme aux enfants dans les
collèges dans les lycées
est ce que c'est une vraie problématique
aujourd'hui à laquelle vous êtes
confrontés côté à maisons-laffitte
jusqu'à présent en dehors d'un cas d'un
animateur sportif qui avait refusé de
serrer la main aux femmes sous prétexte
que c'était une femme nous n'avons
heureusement pas eu de cas mais
je ne suis pas du tout étonné sur ce qui
se passe dans certaines villes des
yvelines
et vous savez il s'agit pas de parler
les écoles auraient été les écoles c'est
le reflet de ce que sont les quartiers
ne jamais oublier que les écoles
accueillent toute la population des
quartiers là où elles sont implantées
selon la carte scolaire
donc nous savons pertinemment qu'il y à
de profonds radicalisation de certains
quartiers et on les retrouve bien sûr à
l'école alors comment agir et c'est là
où aujourd'hui on a constaté qu'il y
avait eu un retard à l'allumage
depuis des années de l'instruction
publique de l'éducation nationale et que
dans un premier temps s'était pas de
vagues
on calme les choses on essaie d'arrondir
les angles en été on a rendu rien du
tout face à quelque chose qui est un
franc sillage de la situation
internationale et de la cri de l'islam
au niveau international car voyez bien
que dans ce cas pas tant comme dans le
cas précédent où c'est un pakistanais
l'a71 tchétchène ces gens là ont importé
leur haine et leur conviction religieuse
en arrivant en france et c'est là où on
a été d'une naïveté complète car il faut
contrôler et bien évidemment les gens
qui rendent chez nous et aussi pouvoir
expulser très rapidement les gens qui se
conduisent contrairement à l'ordre
public
non pas l'orgue avec je dirais un casque
de ses ex
c'est allé assez l'ordonnancement
juridique de notre société qui est mise
à mal et on veut imposer la charia c'est
à dire la loi divine de l'interprétation
du coran par les intégristes
voilà donc il ya pour moi
malheureusement connaissant la dérive de
l'islam depuis une trentaine d'années
ayant fait un syndrome de rapport à
l'assemblée nationale je suis désolé
c'est odieux de ce que je vais dire mais
je ne suis pas malheureusement pas
surpris et je peux vous dire que un ami
professeur dans une autre ville des
yvelines vient de m'appeler pour me dire
attention je suis aussi très fébrile
parce que nous avons des menaces alexis
poule a on entendait aller à l'instant
jacques ménard nous dire que c'était la
politique du pas de vagues dans les
écoles dans l'éducation nationale ce
drame qu'est ce qu'il révèle pour vous
sur la liberté pédagogique des
professeurs aujourd'hui elle n'a pas été
assez défendue non elle n'a pas été
assez défendu c'est vrai qu'il faut
rappeler que les professeurs ont cette
liberté pédagogique qui leur permettent
d'adapter le programme de le suivre bien
entendu mais de pouvoir choisir comment
aborder les thématiques du programme et
donc ça c'est extrêmement important et
je crois que depuis des années mais ce
n'est pas propre à l'école je pense
c'est propre à toutes les organisations
notamment dans le domaine du privé on a
un séparatisme grandissant entre la
direction les directions et puis les
exécutants ceux qui sont face élèves
face à consommateurs ceux qui
travaillent
vous avez d'un côté les directions qui
pense avec des chiffres qui parlent
agilité qui veulent changer le système
qui ont des grandes idées pédagogique
pour le cas de l'éducation nationale et
puis en face vous avez la réalité du
terrain et quand les professeurs
remontait cette réalité à leur proviseur
à leur recteur on leur disait pas de
vagues
je crois que ça suffit c'est partout
pareil quand c'était à france télécom il
ya eu des vagues de suicides ce
séparatisme delà des directions doit
cesser aujourd'hui c'est les gens au
front ce qu'ils sont face les élèves
ceux qui sont les soignants faso covin
cela qu'on doit écouter ceux là qui
doivent décider et arrêter avec ce
management par par parle par le tableau
excel pas par le par le chiffrer par
l'idéologie parce que derrière le fait
d'avoir lâché les professeurs depuis
tant d'années c'est qu'on arrive à cet
extrême et c'est terrible parce que oui
ça ça a pu être une bonne chose à un
moment de faire entrer les parents
d'élèves à l'école pour qui un dialogue
pourquoi on rencontre les professeurs
pour qu'on comprenne comment se faisait
l'éducation des enfants à l'école mais
un moment l'école de la république elle
n'a pas ouvrir ses portes pour tout le
monde et je crois qu'elle est
suffisamment bien fait pour continuer à
former à éduquer à élever les futurs
citoyens que sont les jeunes élèves donc
il faut maintenant changer la version de
la courbe de de la façon dont ont été
gérés le management au sein des
rectorats et faire que les professeurs
soient entendues et puisse à nouveau
reprendre le pouvoir
pour la suite des cours et l'éducation
telle qu'elle doit être faite
aujourd'hui et protéger jacques
milliards effectivement il ya cette
question de la place des parents dans
l'enseignement dans les écoles de la
république qui est qu'est ce que vous en
pensez quelle relation
aujourd'hui l'école doit-elle à avoir
avec les parents la relation professeurs
parents comment est ce qu'elle voit
évoluer la question des parents dans
l'école tout l'est pas les parents
d'élèves militaire s'est jamais facile
mais en l'occurrence ça n'a rien à voir
ici on est dans un cas véritablement où
vous avez des intégristes religieux qui
veulent imposer leur loi au mépris des
lois de la république
je le redis les écoles ce collège comme
d'autres sont le reflet de la société et
doivent accueillir les enfants le
problème c'est que nous avons des
enfants qui veulent imposer leur loi
parce que ils sont dans une mouvance
islamique qui est directement contraire
à l'enseignement français donc il faut
d'abord commencer si vous voulez ramener
de la sérénité dans les écoles il faut
commencer par amener de la sérénité et
des sanctions dans ses banlieues
et c'est là où on doit prendre des
sanctions car il voit bien aujourd'hui
dans cette enquête qu'il ya eu un
certain nombre d'intégrés systémique qui
tenait des propos qu'ils véhiculaient
des convictions qui sont directement
contraires à l'ordonnancement juridique
français et c'est là où il faut les
expulser très rapidement et pour
expulser aujourd'hui il faut modifier
légèrement à la constitution française
car on est dans une complexité sans nom
où c'est en définitive ça dure des
années des années avec certains avocats
qui disent c'est le moment de pouvoir
agir et d'avoir un fonds de commerce
il faut que les expulsions pour tous ces
gens là qui tiennent des propos
contraires à l'ordre public français
soit d expulsion administrative sur la
jurée
sion administrative et il faut modifier
la constitution sur ce point ensuite il
faut contrôler nos frontières parce que
aujourd'hui on a des frontières qui
notamment permettent à chaque individu
d'arriver sur le territoire français
très facilement de demander la
protection des conventions de genève des
réfugiés politiques et à moins que ça ne
soit juge et ça dure des années
donc il est il est manifeste que nous
accueillons aujourd'hui sur le terrain
tu as français des gens qui sont
absolument pas dans l'ordre juridique
français et il ya un moment il faut
arrêter
nous avons été naïfs collectivement
joseph verser un élément fort allez-y et
on en entendra ensuite noah manoir un
policier délégué syndical visite du
haras rejoint en 2003 j'ai participé
avec président jean louis debré a une
mission d'information sur la laïcité à
l'école
en 2003 déjà nous avions entendu des
appels au secours des professeurs nous
disons on ne peut plus enseigner
correctement on ne peut plus parler des
religions parce que certains dès qu'on
parle de l'islam il y avait des reçus en
disant toi tu n'es pas musulmane ne doit
pas nous parler de l'islam de parler de
la shoah donc on a laissé faire on a
crié et moi je me souviens que j'avais
été l'un des premiers à organiser à
l'assemblée nationale un forum sur la
laïcité on sait très bien que ça a duré
pendant des années et qu'on a laissé
pourrir la situation
ce qui n'est pas acceptable alors on va
revenir du côté de l'anc est avec vous
noah manoir vous nous avez rejoint vous
êtes policier délégué syndical vie
j bonsoir alors trois jours après
l'attentât de conflans on le disait 15
personnes en garde à vue quatre
collégiens contact entre le tueur et des
parents d'élèves qui dénonçaient des
caricatures on apprend également que le
terroriste a distribué de l'argent aux
collégiens en échange de renseignements
sur le professeur assassiné on a la
sensation effectivement que derrière
tout ça il y à un réseau enfin en tout
cas une nébuleuse
dans le même temps une note des
renseignements qui a pu consulter arte
france qui indique qu'au sein du collège
aucune tension majeure n'est palpable
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de tout ça
noah manoir alors permettez-moi de
rectifier votre propos j'ai pu consulter
la note du renseignement territoriales
à aucun moment la note ne précise qu
aucune tension n'est palpable au sein du
collège
effectivement la note se veut optimiste
quant à une possibilité de résolution de
conflits suite à des excuses qui avait
été prononcée par l'enseignant suite à
une médiation qui avait été initiée par
la responsable d'établissement entre des
parents et enseignants mais à aucun
moment le renseignement territoriale ne
prévoient ou des formel sur un
apaisement des tensions ou du conflit
ensuite effectivement il ya peut-être un
défaut de recommandation de la part des
services de police quant à la mise en
place d'une protection pour cet
enseignant
quant à peut-être une éventuelle
exclusion des élèves et des éléments
perturbateurs donc écouté il ya
peut-être effectivement des prospectives
qui ont manqué de la part des analystes
du service départemental de
renseignement territoriale ensuite
écouté on peut pas refaire le match je
dirais après coup c'est ce qui est
arrivé est arrivé il faut en tirer les
conclusions est ce qu on veut parler de
ces c'est quoi c'est un réseau ou alors
c'est un un enchaînement de faits
finalement qui ont amené à ce drame
écoutez moi j'ai eu la particularité au
moment de l'exercice de au sein du
renseignement territoriale 93 de suivre
monsieur sefrioui en 2009 c'est à dire
que c'est quelqu'un qui n'est absolument
pas un inconnu pour les services de
police si j'étais amené à croiser demain
il me reconnaîtrait parfaitement et je
le connais parfaitement
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a jamais changé de
cap c'est à dire c'est quelqu'un qui a
toujours manifesté un antisémitisme et
antisionisme une hostilité à la
république française de façon
extrêmement virulente c'est quelqu'un
qui a adopté cette attitude
sweety suite à la nommer à son décret en
fait de naturalisation qu'il a obtenue
par mariage avec une femme d'origine
franco françaises converties à l'islam
donc c'est quelqu'un qui a manifesté une
certaine arrogance en fait à l'encontre
de la république puisque une fois qui
s'est senti en sécurité de part
justement sa naturalisation
il a manifesté des propos anti
républicain il a même eu une influence
très néfaste sur la jeunesse française à
travers des vecteurs numérique à travers
des manifestations organisées sur la
voie publique à travers également des
prières organisées dans la rue des défis
ouvert lancé à des élus républicains
il a entre autres tenté de déstabiliser
un certain nombre de chefs
d'établissements comme à saint-ouen j
étais moi-même j'étais en charge de ce
dossier
j'étais là le soir ou à montreuil il a
organisé un pugilat en règle avec des
jeunes banlieusards pour terroriser
devant les caméras de télévision des des
élus dont manuel valls a à l'époque où
il était député jean pierre brard à
montreuil
des militantes des confédération
étudiante et de ni ni soumises
dont qui ont été violentés c'est à dire
que des hommes ont frappé des femmes au
visage et à dire à coups de poing de
façon très violente sur ordre de ce
monsieur à l'époque on a entamé
également des procédures judiciaires à
la mairie d'epinay sur seine
ils avaient organisé des prières de rue
contre monsieur avec chevron qui était
maire d'epinay sur seine et qui avait
décidé d'octroyer un local municipal à
la mosquée de paris pour y créer une
mosquée républicaine donc et s'est
jamais rien passé entre temps c'est à
dire que il ya une procédure judiciaire
qui ont été initiés on a intenté une
chef de service moi même et le préfet
lambert à l'époque une tentative pour
déchoir de sa nationalité française ce
monsieur et je constate avec dépit que
onze ans plus tard
ce monsieur est toujours là et j'ai pas
besoin de vous rappeler les faits de
vendredi dernier
mais si vous voulez moi je j'avais
décidé de pas m'exprimer sur ce dossier
parce que je vais pas redire ce que j'ai
toujours dit en tout cas dans un manoir
des mesures gérald darmanin vient de
demander la fermeture de la mosquée de
pantin
alexis poulains avant de vous donner la
parole je vous propose de regarder la
réaction ce matin du ministre de
l'intérieur
je vais proposer la dissolution du cci
eef et de baraka city des associations
ennemis de la république
il faut arrêter d'être naïf et voir la
vérité en face
il n'y a aucun accommodement possible
avec l'islamisme radical tout compromis
est une compromission
voilà donc plusieurs mesures annoncées
avec ses poulains c'est la réponse qu'on
attend est ce que ces réponses haute à
la hauteur de la situation selon on
espère je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est un
héritage de toutes ces années de
démission d'accommodement avec cet
islamisme qui permettait d'entrer par
toutes les porte qui était entrouverte 1
les parents d'élèves qui poussait pour
faire entrer leur foi dans l'école de la
république et puis on les écoutait avec
bienveillance on était toujours ouvert
au dialogue mais c'était un dialogue
finalement qui étaient utilisés à des
fins politiques donc aujourd'hui si la
politique reprend ses droits
enfin et que les lois sont utilisés et
que dans le cadre du droit on peut
lutter contre ce poison et contre ceux
qui sèment le poison dans l'esprit des
jeunes parce que je veux bien on entend
c'est la faute des réseaux sociaux non
c'est la faute de ces prédicateurs de
haine c'est la faute de ces gens qui
année après année on fait de l'islam une
arme ont fait de l'islam quelque chose
qui allait à l'encontre de d'un principe
de religion de concorde et ceux là
doivent être attaqués et parce que c'est
une question de vie ou de mort
maintenant de la république alors les
grands discours
on en a entendu beaucoup emmanuel macron
veut terroriser les terroristes ils
veulent qu'ils ne dorment plus
tranquille aujourd'hui c'est plutôt les
français qui ne tend pas tranquille
ne sachant pas si quand ils mettent
leurs enfants à l'école tout va bien se
passer donc il faut vraiment mettre les
moyens et les moyens ça veut dire de
l'argent encore une fois arrêter de
faire croire qu'à pharos avec 28
personnes dédiées aux à la surveillance
des réseaux sociaux ça peut fonctionner
non il en faut peut-être 100 fois plus
pareil avec la façon dont on a traité
cesser ces imams radicaux avec
complaisance ça suffit je crois que on
ne peut pas tolérer sur le territoire
français un des
finalement des ennemis de la république
qui passent leur temps à instiller un
poison qui va jusqu'à pousser au meurtre
certains certains jeunes même si en
l'occurrence c'était un jeune tchétchène
mais voilà le problème nous avons
affaire ici à une idéologie politique
internationale en dehors des frontières
mais qui est bien l'utiliser à des fins
politiques pour déstabiliser la
république donc il est temps que la
république se défendent et j'espère que
la réponse oui sera à la hauteur mais là
encore reste à voir ce reste des
propositions on parle de deux
associations enfin je crois que c'est
une soixantaine en réalité 231 fichier
est ce qu'ils seraient raccompagnés à la
frontière toutes les obligations de
quitter le territoire français j'espère
vont cette fois ci être mise en exercice
pour les radicaliser a minima et voilà
ce qu'on est ce qu'on aimerait voir et
entendre dans les semaines qui viennent
pour que enfin cesse ce poison permanent
de l'islamisme sur notre territoire
jacques milliards en quelques mots ce
matin marine le pen a parlé de
défaillance administrative le tueur
était d'origine tchétchène ont la dînée
à moscou il avait un titre de séjour
délivré le 4 mars dernier
est ce que les services de l'état ont
fauté selon vous écoutez quand j'entends
notre ami policier
je suis stupéfait par ce que il n'ya pas
une histoire il ya une protohistoire est
évident qu'il ya eu manipulation par cet
homme là sur les réseaux est ce parce
que vous savez c'est une manipulation
qu'est ce que cette l'islam radical
c'est une conception du monde qui vous
apprennent totalement c'est qu'une quasi
secte et malheureusement dans l'histoire
de l'islam c'est récurrent depuis des
siècles ou régulièrement il y a
malheureusement une vision une
interprétation du livre qui est celle ci
est donc il ya rien de bien nouveau à
mes yeux nous ce qui est évident c'est
que bien sûr cet individu est entré sur
le territoire
je lirai dans un milieu qui était un
milieu radical et qu'on aurait dû y
regarder à deux fois mais quand
j'entends notre ami policier nous
raconter tout ce qu'il laissait sur
l'individu qui a monté en puissance à
travers les réseaux et qu'il n'a pas été
sanctionné qu'il n'a pas été déçu sable
je n'étais française alors là je dis oui
il ya un dysfonctionnement le mot de la
fin
le mot de la fin pour vous noah manoir
emmanuel macron a dit le soir du drame à
la peur doit changer de camp
oui mais comment à écouter aujourd'hui
on pose la question de savoir si on a
fait le bon diagnostic concernant la
situation de cet enseignant et si on
avait dû prendre des mesures on aurait
dû l'entouré en permanence de 2 3 4 ou
peut-être une dizaine de policiers munis
de pistolets automatiques etc savez en
démocratie c'est absolument pas normal
qu'une personne qui va au travail le
matin puis 7 contre achat se déplace
avec une armée de policiers autour
d'elle je pense que dans une société
normale ce serait justement à ces
criminels d'avoir un pistolet ou un
fusil mitrailleur pointé en permanence
pour surveiller leur moindre faux pas
malheureusement c'est pas comme ça que
ça se passe dans la france de 2020 merci
à tous les trois merci à vous alexis
poulain je rappelle que vous êtes
éditorialistes merci à vous jacques
myard mer les républicains de maisons
laffitte dans les yvelines
merci à vous noah manoir délégué
syndical vichy